John berry working with ESPN radio game
to last night in Golden State John joins
us now what did you think when Golden
State was down 15 at halftime
I thought the Warriors were in trouble
you know they were being outplayed
basically Portland was just playing
harder obviously you know when you win a
game 1 and you win it rather handily
that second game that that teams gonna
come back a lot hungrier make some
adjustments play harder and I really
thought the Warriors be ready for it and
they weren't what's the Warriors
comeback inevitable though well you know
they're gonna eat every team's gonna
make a run how quick they did it was
amazing I mean and it happens on the
defensive end you always think you know
on a team that gets down 17 20 points
yeah you got a score points but you got
a stop and their defense went to a
championship level
I mean draymond Green is an incredible
defender they trapped a ball last night
so hard their rotations were there and
then they got on the boards and they
they just played harder than Portland
and down 17 they found a way to get it
done
yeah and golden state dominated inside
you don't hear that very often but if
Portland's going to concentrate on the
perimeter
you know they better keep an eye on the
paint because well I guess it's pick
your poison a little bit here did you
feel that way in the second half well
yeah they get 25 second-chance points do
the Warriors and they shoot over 51% so
that you can't possibly win a game by
giving up those kind of numbers now
obviously we all talked about the
pick-and-roll coverage on Steph Curry
after came on they sagged the big and
they let him get five or seven
uncontested 3-point shots so they
changed it up they did some double
teaming it was good at times but a lot
of times they let you split and got into
the lane and then when you're running to
on the ball it's very difficult to be in
a proper rebounding position so they
gave up a bunch offensive boards
second-chance points and you know look
that was it that was a championship team
that found a way to win a game that they
probably shouldn't want to
they were outplayed for the better part
of it yes Steve Kerr said that they
stole that game now the series goes to
Portland is this a foregone conclusion
no I don't think so I think what you saw
in that first half Portland is certainly
capable of being a team that can give
this team since you know klay Thompson
is not shooting the ball that great
right now Damian Lillard yet to really
get going he's having a hard time
finding any open looks the Warriors
doing a really good job with him taking
the ball out of his hands and making a
crowd that he can't drive in Portland
can play a lot better and that being
said they were down six in Game one to
start the fourth quarter they're up
eight with three and a half to go in
Game two on the road so no I I think
they should feel pretty confident that
they can go up to Portland and old sir
he's John berry he called games 1 and 2
on ESPN Radio for the mothership former
NBA player you know speaking of which
you spent I think 14 years in the NBA
how how many years did your brother
Brent play in the NBA I think he got 14
as well would you rather play against
your brother or with your brother
against by the way no franchise could
handle the both of us on one team we we
wound up going through Houston actually
my dad and I which is shocking that they
wanted to take three of us on but we
never played in any playoff games a lot
of regular-season games and I found it
difficult looking over at him as we were
playing you could kind of sense
sometimes in the crowd that people are
murmuring because they know two brothers
are going at it I sensed that last night
when staff and stuff matched up a few
times but I see a lot of similarities
between the two of them on us that you
know stuff is a lot like Brent and stuff
is more like me and although I'm older
than Brent I think Brent's got more of a
soft spot than I do and Steph has more
of a sauce pot than
would you agree yeah I think that you
know Seth played really well last night
and and you had four steals on his
brother but you're right it's I think
Steph looks like he has a soft spot he
looks like he's just a nice guy but you
know there is that killer instinct and
in the young child
I mean why this guy gets any criticism I
don't know I mean he is he's is a
dynamic a guy that I that I can ever
remember he is so much fun to watch and
he's the warrior system I know Kevin
Durant might be the greatest offensive
player that we've seen but Steph Curry
is the system of the Golden State
Warriors do the Warriors miss Durrant
I think so I think they're a different
team with him I mean he's such a luxury
on the offensive end when things aren't
going well he's a guy that can go get
his own shot regardless of what defense
is being deployed so I'm not gonna say
their offense is better or worse because
there's still scoring points without
them it's just different and he's more
of an isolation player and when he's not
there they're gonna move the basketball
a lot more and if you took every offense
the best player offense will every team
in the NBA their offense is going to be
completely different you know and then
the Warriors are no different
you think the Warriors can win the title
without
Katie I think don't be surprised if he
doesn't play the rest of the year just
based on what I'm hearing
III think Milwaukee is gonna get through
Toronto I think it's going to be a tough
series but I think they're gonna get
through and I think Milwaukee can
legitimately beat the Warriors without
Durant any other news out there I didn't
know if you had reaction to what's gone
on with Zion and the lottery and going
to New Orleans and Anthony Davis where
he's headed ya know I'm not sure I I
hope Zion you know doesn't make a power
play here to start his career and say
I'm not going to New Orleans and you
know just paint that that's that's where
you've got you know that's where the
balls sell and you got to go there so
I'm excited to see him I'm excited to
see it
if David Griffin can get Anthony Davis
to stay in New Orleans I mean I'll be a
dynamic duo when it yeah I don't know if
you'll ever have a better teammate than
Zion Williamson well I don't know how
he's gonna you know what he's gonna look
like in the NBA but I love drew holiday
I think he's terrific and I think it'd
be interesting and maybe the damage is
done Anthony Davis has got to go but it
sure will be a fun three-four combo or
whatever you want to call them and
people think I'm crazy when I make this
comparison I said you know stop
comparing Zion to LeBron or Charles
Barkley he might be a left-handed Blake
Griffin when it's all said and done
Blake came in as a dynamic dunker we
didn't know about his jumper and I said
if he could put up 25 and 12 a night
people might be disappointed in that but
that's what Blake does and so I don't
know what the expectation level is gonna
be for Zion but if you could plug in 25
and 12 for the next eight years like
Blake has that's a pretty good career
John yeah I know that's a good analogy
with Blake Griffin I didn't really think
about him his playmaking ability is
sensational and yeah I mean why can't I
on just be Zion we don't we always have
to compare people yeah II look he
doesn't shoot it great he doesn't shoot
it that poorly and he's gonna have time
to shoot it if you put a big guy on him
that big guy is gonna have to play six
feet off of him if he wants to have any
chance to stay in front of him so he's
gonna have mismatches basically every
single night and just let it transpire I
want to see the guys he's the one one of
a kind I also wondered about this John
you know that you know we talked about
does he want to be in New Orleans if he
had been it if the the Knicks won the
lottery there was a chance they were
gonna trade him to New Orleans for
Anthony Davis he may have ended up in
New Orleans no matter what that's
absolutely true I don't think that the
Knicks could have pulled off on Anthony
Davis trade they just don't have the
pieces but yeah I mean it it the NBA now
is July 1st that that it's like who
cares about the finals in the playoffs
let's just get the July 1
where is LeBron going with where's Katie
and Kyrie are they gonna join up in New
York I mean it's like watching the
Kardashians it's a joke hey good to
visit with you thanks for joining us we
appreciate you being a gamer and we'll
talk to you soon
okay well thank you but that's John
Barry the mothership he took a red-eye
last night from Golden State to Atlanta
and then joined us before he went to bed
so glad Jon being a gamer there joining
us for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]